or the number was 40 and this is the guy
who didn't guess more than two all right
let's roll here so that one went much
smoother than the first time okay there
you go this is the second time now
playing for Team Black Sea are okay see
our chespin and my opponent is saying my
opponent is saying that the stream is
moot mooted I moved it muted oh my
goodness that's like the how many how
many fumbles I'm like am I going to have
aa my goodness the stream just started
and I am chug tied with every other word
nims Oh Indian land let's ask that
Bishop a question what are you going to
do um I feel like I yeah I'm pretty sure
i played this in the last saima let's
let's just pin that night I might want
to pile up on him too oh really do this
let's just chop that guy up really now
that's different all right my opponent
gave me their dark square Bishop what's
my light square Bishop doing my queen
has a lot of lateral movement now hmm
can I get this in b6 and then Bishop d7
I want to try that
this could get very violent my goodness
this could get violent because 83 what
do i do i do a little bit scared of B
683 my bishop drops back like it be for
breaking the pin in other words and then
night b95 I'm these squares all right
rook here is a candidate I don't have a
fantastic King position so I'm doing it
on a lot of thinking I'm going into a
think tank right now be 6 a-6 knight c6
I'm going to go for development you know
what that that last thing that I thought
about before pulling the trigger on this
night move just developing this night
right away was the position is open and
a move like a six is too slow going into
this preventive type of mentality so
forget about trying to watch over a
silly little square I'm not going to
take the net i like my dark square
Bishop my queen could certainly get
kicked around and I might want to
actually run home I could maybe even
yeah I think I have to run home okay b4
b4 night here night here with tempo well
looks so weird doesn't it my queen ran
home she's very scared clearly and I
wonder if I'm going to establish a pond
in the center one day look at the
tsunami of ponds actually there's
somebody in the twitch chat named
tsunami of pond so I need to arm I need
to pick up the pace and two I was trying
to get in h4 and let me put some
pressure on this guy my darks for a
bishop needs to do something she let me
get out of this i need to do b6 Bishop
e7 who cares about moving my darks a
piece that's already developed twice
maybe I could have considered this like
here's going to be annoying isn't it
okay I don't have a great square then
night here my opponent is flying okay
this pond is dropping oh my goodness and
so is my rook haha yes he's gone just
like that alright I have to do something
dangerous I'm gonna end up losing my
rook oh my goodness i'm i'm dead i'm a
big trouble i'm in very big trouble
you see the killer move here you see it
I night here I could just take the pun
and everything's okay and then I have
night checks I'm so dead I'm so dead in
this position we can you see how I'm
gonna get hammered Queen here was
rattled off in a blank man I'm so dead
right here that wasn't the killer move I
don't think although that actually looks
pretty good too Wow let me throw a check
in here this is this is be on this is
beyond ugly right now this is beyond
ugly the killer move i thought was 95
this looks pretty good too though okay
oh my goodness all right i'm gonna end
up having to play down a rope but you
know what as long as I have my tricky
night around in my dark squared Bishop
maybe I could maybe I could do something
exciting night B 5 by the way if I drop
if I was trying to grab that pond the
night would end with a 4got d6 this is a
very ugly game there is the potential
even for c6 and the Queen's on my night
ok let's see if i could have um let's
see if I have any dynamic stuff up my
sleeve so there goes a ruck just like
that gun a better castle and my queen is
well this is one of those positions but
I don't really want to trade a queen
could take this night and then come here
with check let's do that let's try and
be dangerous with my night and Queen the
most deadly combination in chess
remember that the Queen and night tandem
okay are there any tricky checks I need
some tricky checks look at this bishop
he's loving these ponds right here he's
falling in love with the beat the beast
hufton decent abad he's loving it he is
loving it okay this nights ready to do
this what's this clown even doing I need
a lot I need to breathe I need to
breathe and I can't I can't even breathe
okay let's try that let's see what my
opponent does now maybe I could get my
queen in here still their queen is a
little out of play to defend their King
one minute warning for me 153 I got to
work on the clock that is all I have
actually the night is defending here is
that that doesn't seem right that
doesn't seem right I got the tricky
night in the the Queen around I'm on the
bishop I have to watch over these
squares Queens out of play imagine that
this is one of the craziest games I've
played in a while Wow okay how to make
sense of wild positions like this i'm
not sure i have checks two of them and i
can make i could get a perpetual i could
get a perpetual give check okay i could
get at least a perpetual queen here king
here is forced I missing something
better
I could get a perpetual I might need to
go for that is there anything better
should I try to get more I think I have
to go for the perpetual look at the
clock and just never look at this game
again I gotta go for a perpetual try
checks maybe you'll go here and that'll
be me King here will be nice I gotta go
for the perpetual that's the resigned
button okay that's a drop what a
disaster Oh a wonderful example of how
now to play oh man let me back up good
game let's go back here and look at this
mess Jess isn't always pretty is it what
could I be doing different those ponds
they look at look how they were just a
giant wave on the queenside wow what a
lucky duck I I turned out to be there
huh get away with the drop my opponent
dumb could have really knocked me out
and I don't know how I think it's the
pawn structure that I'm struggling with
here maybe I should just break this pin
with g5 need some more I need to do some
more homework in this particular line I
this isn't the first time that I've
gotten into trouble with this particular
variation but I uh I don't do any
homework opening was so is this okay i
mean i have the bishop pair this was the
other move i didn't say it in the game
but this was the other move i was
considering in in hindsight maybe maybe
i should have been going for this and no
no I yeah I should have gone for it you
know I was on blind to something here so
let me point out how I was blind I was
blind about after pawn takes I was thing
King I had to do this but I don't pawn
takes if capture I could take with my
queen the night's still pinned and that
would have been much better so I think
structurally just looking at particular
pawn advances that would have helped out
my pieces I won't have gotten pushed
around so much for sure d5 establish a
presence in the center that's maybe how
I could have been improving that's just
one quick thought instead of night there
now I get kicked around tempo tempo
space space and soon enough oh man maybe
even still try and get something in here
but I think that its earliest point d5
was best so the killer the killer move
here Queen there is very nice hits the
night maybe the rook and the pond and
just like that my rook is dead i have no
coordination after Queen c7 the killer
move is not here I have no time to take
this pond how bad is this position for
me after night here so bad that my queen
has to go back home for a second time
night b5 Queen back and then you take
the rook ouch ouch ouch night b5 Queen
takes pawn 96 fork that would have been
game over how could how could white have
done better even at this point because
still up a rook hmm one thing I think is
to not grab this pond who cares about
winning this pond I think keeping this
night around or even be in a position to
get rid of this night because when you
look at how can I possibly save this
game it's going to have to come with the
coordination of my queen and night
that's all I have even contributing in
this position so how should you finish
this game off here keep in mind the
night my night is attacking the rook and
the bishop but the bishop is defended
how about something like this maybe even
getting in a position where you give up
some material take out this night keep
in mind you're up a full rook and these
pieces are at doing absolutely nothing
so this I think you're going maybe in a
not-so-good direction because i get to
centralize my queen and there's too many
different checks maybe this is still
good for you to save but it's certainly
much more difficult to calculate is it
not with all the different Queen
possibilities that I have I'm pretty
sure I had to take the perpetual here I
was looking at little checks like this
Queen check king here I don't know how
to even get Adam it's tough all right
anyhow um I think the last point to make
is uh don't try to get more other
position what's really there in this
position right here when I'm down to
Brooke I really had to just go for a dry
was hoping I had some hope maybe would
go here and then it would be made either
one of these two squares Queen here's me
so good decision to keep going to that a
foursquare alright good game I believe
that was one of the first times may be
the only time that we've played against
one another so good game good good game
i learned something from that okay